THERE YOU GO.
GOOD MORNING WILL GO AHEAD AND
GET STARTED IN THE.
ABSENCE OF A QUORUM WILL START
AS SELECT COMMITTEE.
WAS TO BE WHAT FOR SOME MEMBERS
OF BECOMING THEM. SO THAT I KNOW
WE DO HAVE A MEMBER. PRESIDENT
YOU HAVE ARE YOUR FOLKS WITH
YOU.
SO THE FIRST IN WAR HAVE IS AB
TWENTY SEVENTEEN.
SOME REMEMBER CHAU CHIU IF YOU
GOT. IN YOUR WRITING.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND OF
THE SOON TO BE CONSTITUTE
COMMITTEE. OF AND I KNOW THIS IS
A COMMITTEE THAT UNDERSTANDS THE
IMPORTANCE OF PROTECTING WORKERS
IN OUR STATE AND IN PARTICULAR
THE RESPONSIBILITY PROTECTING
THEM AS A EXERCISE. CRITICAL
LEGAL RIGHTS SUCH AS DECIDING
WHETHER OR NOT TO BECOME A
MEMBER OF A UNION.
THIS BILL.
AB TWENTY SEVENTEEN WOULD
PROHIBIT PUBLIC EMPLOYERS FROM
INTERFERING WITH PUBLIC
EMPLOYEES WHILE EXERCISING THEIR
RIGHT TO HAVE UNION
REPRESENTATION IN THE WORKPLACE.
UP.
SORRY THAT THE CURRENT LAW
PROHIBITS PUBLIC EMPLOYEES FROM
INTERFERENCE.
BUT THESE PROTECTIONS DO NOT AT
THIS MOMENT EXTENT TO
PROSPECTIVE EMPLOYEES
PUBLIC EMPLOYERS COULD INTERPRET
THE LETTER OF THE LAW TO MEAN
THAT THEY COULD A QUESTION A
CANDIDATE DURING THE INTERVIEW
PROCESS ABOUT THEIR INTENT TO
WOOD. TO JOIN A UNION. OUR
INTERVIEW  INTERVIEWEES
COULD BE THRUST INTO SITUATIONS
WHERE THERE INTENT WITH RESPECT
TO JOINING A UNION COULD BECOME
A RELEVANT TO THEIR CANDIDACY OR
JOB APPLICATION.
AT THIS IS A LOOPHOLE THAT HAS
LEFT SOME ROOM FOR
DISCRIMINATION IN THE HIRING
PROCESS.
AND INCONSISTENT WITH THE
PRINCIPLES LAID OUT IN LAW.
WE KNOW THAT IF EMPLOYERS ARE
ALLOWED TO SUCCESSFULLY CONVINCE
PROSPECTIVE EMPLOYEES NOT TO
BECOME UNION MEMBERS THEY WOULD
UNDERMINE THE RIGHT OF ALL
CALIFORNIANS TO FREELY DECIDE
WHETHER OR NOT TO JOIN A UNION.
UP SO WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR AYE VOTE AND HERE TO
TESTIFY FROMAS YOU ARE YOU THE
BILL'S SPONSOR IS MICHELLE
CASTRO.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIRMAN
STOOD ON THE SHOCK CAPS WITH THE
SERVICE EMPLOYEES INTERNATIONAL
UNION. AS MR CHIU SAID THIS BILL
SIMPLY CLOSING A LOOPHOLE THAT
LEFT OUT PROSPECTIVE EMPLOYEES.
IN LAST YEAR'S LAW SB TWENTY
FIVE.
ONE OTHER IN ADDITION TO
PROSPECTIVE CANDIDATES AND OUT
AS THEY'RE INTERVIEWING WAS WE
FOUND.
IN A CERTAIN INSTANCE WHEN IN
HOME SUPPORTIVE SERVICES.
WORKERS FOR.
PARTICIPATING THE NEW EMPLOYEE
ORIENTATION. THAT.
EMPLOYERS OR IN FACT VIOLATING
THIS LONG WITHOUT A WAIT A
MINUTE REVENUE LOSS BETWEEN THE
FIVE YOU'RE VIOLATING IT. AND WE
WERE INFORMED BY THE EMPLOYER
THAT. I JUST US WORKERS AT THE
TIME OF THE NEW EMPLOYEE
ORIENTATION ARE NOT TECHNICALLY
EMPLOYEES ARE JUST PROSPECTIVE
EMPLOYEES.
SO.
WE RECOGNIZE THE LIPPO LA AND
ARE SEEKING TO FIX THAT LOOPHOLE
IN OVERSIGHT IN THIS BILL WE ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU.
FOR THOSE WHO WANT TO GO AHEAD
AND STUFF SHE QUORUM.
US SECRETARY ONE COLOR.
THE MOTION IS THE PATH TO
APPROPRIATIONS.
RODRIGUEZ.
I RODRIGUEZ AYE.
NO MOTION A WORD STUFF SHOWING.
QUORUM.
RODRIGUEZ
YOU'RE.
ALLEN.
BROUGH.
FOR BONTA.
COOLEY.
COOPER THERE.
AND O'DONNELL.
WITHOUT GOING CONTINUE ANYONE
ELSE TO SUPPORT DUFFEL VOCAL
WITH THE AMERICAN FEDERATION OF
STATE COUNTY
THE POEM PLEASE ALSO IN SUPPORT.
CHAIR MEMBERS PACMAN WITH THEIR
AND READING ASSOCIATES
REPRESENTING THE ORANGE COUNTY
EMPLOYEES ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN CHRIS
pCALIFORNIA PROFESSIONAL
FIREFIGHTERS IN SPORTS.
GOOD MORNING BEVERLY YOU WITH
UPW ASKED ME LOCAL THIRTY NINE
THIRTY IN SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING SANDRA BARRERA ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
EMPLOYEES ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT.
MICHAEL YOUNG ABOUT THE
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION ALSO
HERE STRONG SUPPORT.
BRIAN CHAIRMAN WITH THE
RIVERSIDE SHERIFF'S ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT.
IS THERE ANYONE IN OPPOSITION TO
THE MEASURE.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE ANY
QUESTION COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
I I'D LIKE TO JUST MAKE MORE OF
AN OBSERVATION ARM.
I ACTUALLY VERY SUPPORTIVE OF
THIS BILL.
THOUGH.
.%
MY ONE ARMS RACES.
THE STATUTE CURRENTLY TALKS
ABOUT THE ON BOARDING PROCESS
I ASSUME THAT ANY IN A
JURISDICTION MAY HAVE. VARIOUS
PARTIES THAT ARE PART OF THE ON
BOARDING PROCESS.
THEY'LL BE A PART OF THAT
EMPLOYEE ORIENTATION.
.
AND SAW I UNDERSTAND US IN
PRECLUDING.
BROAD NOTICE.
THAT SESSION IS BEING HELD WHICH
I AGREE WITH DIFFICULT.
OR WAS IT WILL GET REPEAL ALL
THIS ONCE ABOUT THE.
UP PUBLIC EMPLOYEES DETERRING
ARE.
DISCOURAGING AND I'M SORRY I'M
GETTING AHEAD OF MYSELF NO
WORRIES.
PAUL BUT I APPRECIATE THE
ENGAGEMENT VERY GOOD.
YEAH.
GOOD I THOUGHT O'DONNELL IT
REMOTELY THAT OUT.
RELATED FIRST PERIOD.
WOULD THAT HOW LEAVE THAT AS
YOUR.
NO QUESTIONS.
IT WE NEED A MOTION TO SECONDS
OUR MOTION SECOND.
MOTION BY SUMMER BECAUSE I
MEMBERS COOPER.
I DO HAVE IRAQ ON THIS.
AND THINK HER MUCH BRINGS BILL
FORD I THINK IT'S MUCH NEEDED
AND THANK YOU CENTER LIKE
CALDERON.
OR OBSERVER THAT BEFORE THAT YOU
WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE.
WE ASK FOR A VOTE AND APPRECIATE
YOUR CONSIDERATION.
THANK YOU.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS
TO APPROPRIATIONS RODRIGUEZ.
RODRIGUEZ AYE ALLEN.
PEROT.
CERVANTES
COOLEY.
COOLEY AYE COOPER.
COOPER I O'DONNELL.
O'DONNELL I.
WITH THAT MOTION PASSES FOR SURE
WILL KEEP THE ROLE OPEN FOR
OTHER MEMBERS COMMENT THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
AND WITH THAT BEFORE WE GO ANY
FURTHER ANNOUNCEMENT THIS
MORNING. AS WE HAVE SEVEN ITEMS
ON THE AGENDA TODAY FILE ITEM
NUMBER FIVE AB TWENTY FOUR
EIGHTY ONE. FOUR PILLS ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR.
WE'LL TAKE OF THE CONSOLE COLOR
AS SOON AS WE HAVE OVER HERE
WHICH WE DO AS WELL AND ALSO THE
COMMITTEE HAS RECEIVED NOTICE
FROM SOME REMARK THURMAN'S
OFFICE THAT ASSEMBLY MEMBER
COOPER. WILL BE PRESENTING AB
TWENTY ONE SIXTY ON HIS BEHALF.
ALSO MR ALLEN OR NOT WILL BE
ABSENT AT TODAY'S MEETING AS
WELL.
SO THAT US SECTOR LET'S GO AHEAD
AND DO THE CONSENT CALENDAR
SINCE WE DO HAVE A QUORUM.
AB TWENTY FOUR EIGHTY ONE THE
MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS TO CONSENT.
RODRIGUEZ TIME.
ALLEN.
BRO.
CERVANTES.
COOLEY.
COOLEY AYE COOPER AYE COOPER AYE
O'DONNELL.
O'DONNELL I.
CONSENT DOLLAR CALENDARS VOTED
OUT A FOR.
KEEP THE ROLE OF MS WELL.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER COOPER JOINED
PRESENT ON THURMAN'S BILL.
SO ONCE AGAIN SOME AMERICA BURN
WILL BE PRESENTING AB TWENTY ONE
SIXTEEN ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER THURMAN.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WHEN YOU'RE
READY.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN FIRST
I HAPPEN TO BE PRESENT AB TWENTY
ONE SIXTY WHICH PROVIDE EQUITY
DEPART.
WE'RE CURRENTLY EXCLUDED
UNCLASSIFIED SERVICE.
THIS BILL IS THE CLEAN UP TO AB
SIX SEVENTY OF LAST YEAR.
UNFORTUNATELY THAT LANGUAGE DID
NOT INCLUDE MAYOR BASS SCHOOL
DISTRICTS AND COMMUNITY
COLLEGES.
THE RESULT OF THE EXCLUSION
MEANS THAT THOSE WORKERS.
STILL NOT RECEIVING THICKLY
VACATION ARE BEREAVEMENT LEAVE
LEVELS BILLS IN SCHOOL OTHER
SCHOOLS DO.
AS PART TIME PLAY GOT EMPLOYEES
COOPER EE WOMEN
I TYPICALLY THE LOWEST WAGE
EARNERS AT THE SCHOOL SITE.
SUPERVISE STUDENTS DURING
BREAKFAST AND LUNCH PERIODS
ESCORTING A MONITORING STUDENTS
DURING PLAYTIME.
ASSISTING CLASSIFIED AND
CERTIFIED STAFF.
STUDENT RELATED NEEDS.
AB TWENTY ONE SIXTY CLEANS UP
THE CODE AND ENSURES FAIRNESS AS
WELL AS EQUITY AND RIGHTS
BENEFITS AND PROTECTIONS FOR ALL
SCHOOL EMPLOYEES WORKING IN PART
TIME PLAYGROUND POSITIONS.
WITH ME IS CENTER BERRYHILL A
FIFTH OF THAT RIGHT REPEATING
SPONSORED THE BILL THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL EMPLOYEES
ASSOCIATION.
OUR STATE WE ASK FOR YOUR I'VE
OF.
THANK YOU HAD.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS SANDRA BORRERO ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
EMPLOYEES ASSOCIATION. ARE THE
ONLY THING THAT I WOULD ADD TO
TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER COOPER
STATEMENT IS THAT AB TWENTY ONE
SIXTY COVERS ALL LESS THAN ONE
HUNDRED MERIT SCHOOL DISTRICTS.
AND INCLUDING BECAUSE OF A
COMMUNITY COLLEGES. IN OF THIS
BILL IS SIMPLY CLEAN UP OF
EDUCATION CODE SINCE THERE ARE
CURRENTLY NO PART TIME
PLAYGROUND POSITIONS.
IN COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
THANK YOU I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE.
TURN ONE ELSE IN SUPPORT OF THIS
MEASURE.
MICHELLE CAST OF THE SERVICE
EMPLOYEES INTERNATIONAL UNION
ALSO SUPPORT.
JOSH WILL BOOK WITH THE AMERICAN
FEDERATION OF STATE COUNTY
MUNICIPAL EMPLOYEES IN SUPPORT.
MICHAEL YOUNG THE MAP THE
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION HERE
SUPPORT.
POSSIBLE MOMBI AFTER THE
CALIFORNIA PROFESSIONAL
FIREFIGHTERS SUPPORT.
SEEN THAT ANYBODY ELSE IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS MEASURE.
SENATE HEARING NONE ANY
QUESTIONS COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
WITHOUT THE SUMMER LIKE TO A
CLOSE
ESPECIALLY AFTER I VOTE.
AND THAT WILL BRING THEM BACK WE
HAVE WELL. GARDEN.
WHAT WORK THAT I DID OF IRAQ ON
THIS?
WE DON'T HAVE A MOTION AND
SECOND.
WITHOUT HAVE MUCH IN SECOND
SECTOR LIKE COLOR.
WE GOT.
RODRIGUEZ I.
RODRIGUEZ AYE ALLEN.
GROW.
FOR BONTA IT'S.
COOLEY.
COOPER AYE COOPER AYE O'DONNELL.
O'DONNELL I.
THE MOTION BE ON CALL WE HAVE A
THREE ZERO.
WITH THAT WE HAVE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CALDERON ELECT COMES.
FORWARD AND PRESENT.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CURRENTLY HAVE AB
TWENTY FOUR FIFTEEN GOING READY
SIR.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS A. B. TWENTY FOUR
FIFTEEN WILL GIVE THE. CALPERS
BOARD THE AUTHORITY TO APPOINT
AND FIX THE COMPENSATION FOR ITS
CHIEF HEALTH DIRECTOR AND DEPUTY
EXECUTIVE OFFICER POSITIONS.
STATE LAW GIVES THE CALPERS
BOARD A OF ADMINISTRATION THE
AUTHORITY TO APPOINT AND FIX THE
COMPENSATION OF ITS C. E. O.
GENERAL COUNSEL CHIEF. ACTUARY
CHIEF INVESTMENT OFFICER CFO
ANOTHER INVESTMENT MANAGEMENT
POSITIONS THIS AUTHORITY ALLOWS
CALPERS ASCETIC COMPENSATION FOR
THESE POSITIONS SO I TO BE
COMPETITIVE WITH OTHER AGENCIES
IN THE PRIVATE SECTOR FOR
PROSPECTIVE CANDIDATES. HOWEVER
CALPERS DOES NOT HAVE THE
AUTHORITY TO SET THE
COMPENSATION FORCE CHIEF HEALTH
DIRECTOR OR CHIEF EXIT DEPUTY
EXECUTIVE OFFICER POSITIONS.
HAVING COMPENSATION FOR ITS CHD
AND D. E. O. POSITIONS SET BELOW
THAT OF SIMILAR AGENCIES IN THE
PRIVATE SECTOR MAKES IT
DIFFICULT FOR THE CALPERS BOARD.
TO RECRUIT AND RETAIN TALENT IN
THESE POSITIONS A NEAR CONSTANT
HIRING PROCESS FOR THESE
POSITIONS UNDERMINES CALPERS
BOARD. A EXCUSE ME CALPERS
ABILITY TO PLAN FOR THE
SUCCESSION OF ITS
EXECUTIVE LEADERSHIP TEAM AND
MEET ITS FIDUCIARY DUTIES THIS
BILL WILL GIVE THE CALPERS BOARD
THE AUTHORITY TO APPOINT AND FIX
THE COMPENSATION. FOR.
OF THOSE TWO POSITIONS THIS
SIMPLY THIS SIMPLE CHANGE WILL
ALLOW THE BOARD OF THE.
TO MORE EFFECTIVELY RECRUIT AND
RETAIN TALENT PLAN FOR THE
SUCCESSION OF ITS EXECUTIVE
LEADERSHIP TEAM AND MEET ITS
FIDUCIARY DUTIES I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE WITH ME
TODAY AND TO TEST IN SUPPORT.
I'D MARION ACTUALLY IN CHARLES
MASON WHO MAY BE A LITTLE LATE
TODAY FROM CALPERS.
GARTNER THANK YOU GOOD MORNING
CHAIR RODRIGUEZ A MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE I'M MARIANNE
NATIONALLY WITH THE CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC EMPLOYEES RETIREMENT
SYSTEM. CALPERS IS THE SPONSOR
OF THIS MEASURE AND I WOULD LIKE
TO THANK ASSEMBLY MEMBER CALLED
FROM FOR BRINGING FORWARD THIS
REALLY IMPORTANT MEASURE.
I THINK THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER DID
A EXCELLENT JOB PRESENTING Y.
THIS MEASURE IS SO NECESSARY AND
AND IMPORTANT TO CALPERS. BEING
ABLE TO BE COMPETITIVE IN THE
RECRUITMENT AND RETENTION OF
KEY.
LEADERSHIP POSITIONS AND AND
COMPETE FOR CANDIDATES THAT
HAVE.
SPECIALIZED KNOWLEDGE AND SKILL
SETS IN THAT ARE HIGHLY
QUALIFIED IS A TOP PRIORITY FOR
CAL PERS.
A AS AN ASSEMBLY MEMBER NOTED
CALPERS IS FINDING IT.
INCREASINGLY DIFFICULT.
TO COMPETE FOR.
THESE POSITIONS BECAUSE WERE
COMPETING NOT ONLY WITH THE
PRIVATE SECTOR BUT ALSO WITH
OTHER STATE AGENCIES AND SIMILAR
RETIREMENT SYSTEMS HOME FOR
EXAMPLE.
CAL STIRS OUR SISTER AGENCY
ACROSS THE THE RIVER JUST
RECENTLY.
OBTAINED AUTHORITY FOR A CHIEF
OPERATING OFFICER FOR THEIR
POWER TO UPSET THE PERFORMANCE
STANDARDS. AND COMPENSATION FOR
THAT POSITION.
SO PROVIDING CALPERS BOARD THE
AUTHORITYTO SET THE PERFORMANCE
STANDARDS AND COMPENSATION FOR
CHIEF HEALTH DIRECTOR AND A
CHIEF OPERATING OFFICER.
WILL I HELP THE BOARD EVER IN
ITS EFFORTS OF RECRUITING AND
RETAINING TOP TALENT FOR THESE
VERY CRUCIAL POSITIONS. AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
I THINK ANYONE ELSE SPORT.
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING DOROTHY JOHNSON OF
THE CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION
OF COUNTIES AND STRONG SUPPORTER
AND ALSO MAY HAVE MY COLLEAGUE
WITH THE LEAGUE OF CALIFORNIA
CITIES PLACES SUPPORT THANK YOU.
MORNING DELUDE GIBBONS FOR THE
CALIFORNIA SPECIAL DISTRICTS
ASSOCIATION ALSO IN SUPPORT
THINK.
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT.
SENATE HEARING ON ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS MEASURE.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE ANY
COMMITTEE.
.
COMMENTS BY COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
WE HAVE A MOTION.
I CAN'T.
SO AT THAT ARSON RIGHT CLOSE
UNDERGO.
THANK YOU MEMBERS YOUR TIME IN
RESPECT WE ASK FROM ABOUT.
THANK YOU SO WE DO HAVE MORE
SECOND I DO HAVE IRAQ ON THIS
THANK YOU MEMBER BRINGS FORWARD
ANSWERED EARLY KALRA.
THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS RODRIGUEZ AYE
RODRIGUEZ AYE ALLEN.
PEROT.
CERVANTES
COOLEY.
COOPER A COOPER AYE O'DONNELL.
O'DONNELL I.
OTHER MOTIONS THREE ZERO WERE
SHORT ONE SO WE'RE GOING TO KEEP
THE ROLE OPEN WHICH ONLY ABOUT.
SOME MEMBERS CERVANTES LIKE AT
ON TO THIS
BUT WE JUST HEARD I WAS.
.
CALDERON SPILL AB TWENTY FOUR
FIFTEEN.
WE HAVE AN EXTENSION.
THE THOUGHT MOTIONS TO BE ON
CALL.
DON'T HAVE ANY OTHER MEMBERS
STORED FOR SOME.
SUMMER COOPER.
OWN YOUR
OKAY GO AT IT REPEAL OF DUTCH
COMPUTER THURMAN QUITE.
I DID NOT. I THOUGHT WAS
THURMAN'S BILL YOU'RE DOING.
SO THAT WE HAVE A SUMMER COOPER
AB TWENTY NINE SEVENTY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WHEN YOU'RE READY.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS. AB TWENTY
NINE SEVENTY WITH SIMPLY
CLARIFY.
THAT NOTICE OF NEW EMPLOYEE
ORIENTATION SHOULD BE ONLY
PROVIDED TO THE NEW EMPLOYEES
MANAGEMENT. IN THE EXCLUSIVE
REPRESENTATIVE IN ORDER TO
ENSURE THE SAFETY OF THOSE
EMPLOYEES AND MANAGEMENT.
LAST YEAR AS A RESULT OF
CALIFORNIA'S PROJECTED INFLUX OF
NEW EMPLOYEES
THE LEGISLATURE ADOPTED AB ONE
NINETEEN. WHICH REQUIRED ALL THE
PUBLIC EMPLOYEES.
PROVIDED ORIENTATION.
DISORIENTATION WOULD ALLOW NEW
EMPLOYEES DEAR FROM BOTH THE
EMPLOYER AND THE EMPLOYEE
ORGANIZATION BUT THEIR NEW JOB
THE CONTRACTUAL RIGHTS.
THE LAW ALSO REQUIRES THE
EXCLUSIVE REPRESENTATIVE RECEIVE
AT LEAST TEN DAYS ADVANCE NOTICE
OF AN ORIENTATION UNLESS
CIRCUMSTANCES.
DON'T PERMIT SUCH NOTIFICATION.
KEEPING LOCATION DATE ANTI
CONFIDENTIAL PREVENT
ORGANIZATIONS FROM ATTENDING IN
ORDER TO STRIP THE MEETING AS
WELL AS ENSURING EMPLOYEES
PRIVACY.
A RECENT REPORT BY US PER OF
JUSTICE STATISTICS
FELT OF THE RATE OF WORKPLACE
VIOLENCE IS THREE TIMES HIGHER.
PUBLIC SECTOR IN THE PRIVATE
SECTOR
MOREOVER BETWEEN TWO THOUSAND
TWO AND TWO THOUSAND ELEVEN.
PERCENT OF PUBLIC EMPLOYEES
SECTOR WORKPLACE VIOLENCE WAS
DIRECTED AT LAW ENFORCEMENT OR
SECURITY OFFICERS.
GIVEN THESE FACTS IS A PAIR THAT
WE PROTECT OUR NEW PUBLIC
EMPLOYEES ATTENDING ORIENTATION
BUT ONLY PROVIDING ADVANCED
NOTICE THE PERTINENT PARTIES.
OUR SPIFFY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
AND WITH THAT WHEN SUPPORT.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS CAITLIN
BAKER FOR THE CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION WE VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
COOPER'S WORK ON ON IN HELPING
US I GET A BILL TO ESTABLISH NEW
EMPLOYEE ORIENTATIONS. WE VIEW
THIS BILL REALLY AS A CLEANUP
MEAURE. IN THE BILL WE CREATED
A NEW ADVANCE NOTICE REQUIREMENT
THAT DID NOT PREVIOUSLY EXIST
AND BECAUSE OF BAD WE REALIZED
AND IT COULD END UP HAVING
ADVERSE CONSEQUENCES IT COULD
RESULT IN. ADVANCE NOTICE GOING
TO PARTIES WHO HAVE.
OBJECTIONS WITH PUBLIC
EMPLOYEES WITH LAW ENFORCEMENT
SPECIFICALLYWITH UNIONS WITH
ANY OF THAT THIS IS AN INTERNAL
MEETING AND OUR INTENT WITH THIS
BILL IS SIMPLY TO KEEP. ADVANCE
NOTICE INTERNAL I HAVE HAD
CONVERSATIONS WITH SOME OF THE
OPPOSITION I BELIEVE WE MAY HAVE
BEEN OVERLY BROAD WE CERTAINLY
DID NOT MEAN TO SAY THAT THEY
COULD NOT TELL THE VENDORS THAT
ARE COMING TO THE ORIENTATION.
TO PROVIDE INFORMATION TO THE
EMPLOYEES
THE TIME DATE LOCATION OF THE
ORIENTATION OF COURSE THAT'S
NECESSARY AND WE'RE HAPPY TO
WORK WITH THEM TO MAKE SURE
THAT.
THE LOGISTICS WORK OUR INTENT
WAS JUST THAT THIS IS AN
MANAGEMENT EMPLOYEES AND THOSE
ARE THE PARTIES THAT NEED THE
ADVANCE NOTICE.
THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE MICHELLE CAST OF THE
SERVICE EMPLOYEES INTERNATIONAL
UNION JUST WANNA.
AFFIRM EVERYTHING SEVEN MISTER
COOPER AND MISS VEGA.
OUR UNION HAS.
REALLY LOOKS AT THIS FOR THE
PROSPECTIVE EMPLOYEE SAFETY WE
HAVE HAD NUMEROUS EMPLOYEES.
.
EXPERIENCE VARYING LEVELS OF
VIOLENCE ON THE JOB RANGING FROM
BEING SHOT AT.
TO BE ATTACKED.
IT WE JUST SEE THIS AS ONE STEP
IN ENSURING THEIR PRIVACY AND
SAFETY SO WE ASK FOR YOUR I.
THINK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE MISTER CHAIRMAN WAS
JUST HORRIBLE CHO WITH THE
AMERICAN FEDERATION OF STATE
COUNTY MUNICIPAL EMPLOYEES FOR
THE REASONS YOU'VE ALREADY HEARD
WERE ALSO IN SUPPORT.
NO ONE ELSE IN SUPPORT OF
MEASURE.
WE HAVE OF THE CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
EMPLOYEES ASSOCIATION AND
SUPPORT.
BEVERLY YOU WITH ETW ASKS ME
LOCAL THIRTY NINE THIRTY IN
STRONG SUPPORT THING.
CHAIR MEMBERS PATRONAGE AND
READING ASSOCIATES REPRESENTING%
THE ORANGE COUNTY EMPLOYEES
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
LET ME SANTA AS LABORS LOCAL
SEVEN NINE TWO IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
SHANE GUSMAN ON BEHALF OF THE
TEAMSTERS THE AMALGAMATED
TRANSIT UNION AYE FPT LOCAL
TWENTY ONE ALL EXPORT.
BRIAN HOW BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA
FEDERATION OF TEACHERS WERE IN
SUPPORT.
NO ONE ELSE IN SUPPORT.
STING HEARING NONE ANYONE
OPPOSITION TO THIS MEASURE.
OKAY ANY QUESTION COMMITTEE
MEMBERS OR NO WE DO HAVE BECOMES
OUR.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIRMAN
BURST FORTH EACH ON SOME OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES AND ALSO BEHALF MY
COLLEAGUE FROM THE LEAGUE OF
CALIFORNIA CITIES. RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED TO THIS
MEASURE A WE UNDERSTAND THE
INTENT OF THE OF THE BILL AND
APPRECIATE THE SPONSORS
AWARENESS OF SOME OF THE
EXISTING CONFLICTS. AYE BUT
UNFORTUNATELY I THINK THIS COULD
ACTUALLY IMPEDE THE VERY PURPOSE
OF THE NEW EMPLOYEE ORIENTATIONS
TO INFORM OUR NEWEST MEMBERS
PRIDE ABOUT THE RESOURCES AND
OPPORTUNITIES.
.
SO I WAS MENTIONS AND I REALLY
DO HOPE WE CAN ADDRESS THIS
PROBLEM OF MANY AGENCIES DOING
BY THIRD PARTY VENDORS. TO
EXPLAIN TO NEW EMPLOYEES
INFORMATION ABOUT A INSURANCE
DEFERRED COMPENSATION OFFERINGS
AND OTHER ADDITIONAL BENEFITS
AND WE ALSO KNOW THAT SOME OF
OUR SAFETY AGENCIES.
INVITE FAMILY MEMBERS BE PART
OF THE BADGE PINNING CEREMONIES
THAT TAKE PLACE AS PART OF THOSE
ORIENTATIONS.
AND THEN FINALLY A SOME ALSO
BRING AND THIRD PARTY EXPERTS
FOR WORKPLACE SAFETY TRAINING
AND HOW TO RESPOND IN AN
EMERGENCY OR CRISIS SITUATION.
IN THE WORKPLACE.
RESPECTFULLY I WANNA SAY THAT
WHILE THE COMMITTEE NOW THIS
REFLECTS NUMBER A NUMBER OF THEM
INCIDENTS UNFORTUNATELY NOT ALL
OF THOSE ACTUALLY BE OUR RESOLVE
TO PROVIDED BY THE PROPOSED ON
AB TWENTY NINE SEVENTY. I'M SO
IN ADDITION TO.
THE PROBLEM WITH THEM BY THE
THIRD PARTY VENDORS INDICATORS
WHICH I THINK WE CAN WORK ON.
THERE'S ALSO THE ISSUE THE
PUBLIC RECORDS ACT
AND WE SEE THIS AS BEING A MAJOR
CONFLICT WITH THE PUBLIC RECORDS
ACT AND THE STANDARD BY WHICH
LOCAL AGENCIES MUST CONDUCT
THEIR BUSINESS.
THERE SOME LOCAL AGENCIES THAT
HAVE.
.
ADOPTED ORDINANCES THAT ARE EVEN
MORE STRENUOUS THAN THE STATE'S
PR A THE SUNSHINE ORDINANCES AND
THAT'S UNFORTUNATE STANDING
CONFLICT.
AND WE SEE THAT AS A DRAIN ON
PUBLIC RESOURCES BECAUSE THE
NEED TO RE DOCKED OR. CREATE
MORE I'VE AYE PAPERWORK FOR THE
PEARY COMPLIANCE IS SIMPLY A
DREAM BECAUSE WE CANNOT SEEK
REIMBURSEMENT FOR THOSE PURPOSES
SO WE DO HOPE TO CAN YOU WORKING
ON BOTH THE APPLICATION OF THE
RESTRICTION. AS WELL AS HOW TO
DEAL WITH THE PR A SENSE
EMPLOYEE EMPLOYER COMMUNICATION
IS NOT EXEMPT CURRENTLY THANK
YOU.
ANYONE ELSE IN OPPOSITION TO
THIS MEASURE.
DILLON GIVENS WITH THE
CALIFORNIA SPECIAL DISTRICTS
ASSOCIATION ALSO.
WITHIN OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED
POSITION WITH LIKE TO THINK THE
AUTHOR TO STAFF AND AND SPONSORS
FOR THEIR WILLINGNESS TO WORK
WITH US TO ADDRESS SOME OF THE
CONCERNS OF THE BILL. ODD LIKE
TO REITERATE THE COMMENTS.
FROM C. SACK.
IN OPPOSITION THANK YOU
GOOD MORNING DEREK LANG SOME
BEHALF A COALITION OF LOCAL
EDUCATIONAL EMPLOYERS FOR THE
REASONS STATED IN OUR LETTER.
MUST RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE ALL ON
BEHALF OF THE ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL ADMINISTRATORS
THE SMALL SCHOOL DISTRICTS
ASSOCIATION THE SCHOOL
PARTICIPATION OF CALIFORNIA.
THE ORANGE COUNTY A DEPARTMENT
OF EDUCATION THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF SCHOOL BUSINESS
OFFICIALS AND RIVERSIDE COUNTY
SUPERINTENDENT OF SCHOOLS. THANK
YOU.
GOOD MORNING DAN HUTCHINSON LIKE
A CALIFORNIA CITIES LIMA COMES
TO SEE ZACK PUZZLES MEDIBANK.
WITH THAT DESERVE ANY QUESTION
COMMITTEE MEMBERS WHAT. THAT IS
THE QUESTION FOR THE AUTHOR OR
OR MAYBE.
THE SPONSOR YOU STATED YOU'RE
GOING TO WORK OUT SOME OF THE
CONCERNS THAT WERE PRESENTED TO
DEATH CORRECT.
AND I AND I DON'T UNDERSTAND THE
BADGE PINNING.
CEREMONY FOR FOR LONG EXAMPLE
AND ON I DON'T KNOW HOW THAT
WOULD FALL UNDER THE PURVIEW OF
WHERE. WHERE THIS IS GOING
BECAUSE RELIGIOUS USUALLY JUST A
CEREMONY?
S. NOT WHERE I THINK THE BIG
ISSUE IS I I'M ON WORK WITH THEM
SOME THEIR CONCERNS NOT VALID A
LOT OF CITIES AND COUNTIES DO IT
RIGHT NOW WITH THE BEING IN
THIRD PARTY VENDORS SO YOU FIRST
ALLIED UP.
FOR DEFERRED COMP WHATEVER DAYS
THEY BRING IN NOW SO YOU KNOW IT
WILL WORK WITH THEM BUT IT
HAPPENS RIGHT NOW SECOND COUNTY
FOR INSTANCE YOU COME IN. THEY
WEREN'T INSURANCE DEFERRED COMP.
UNIONS EVERYTHING'S TIED UP IN
NOTE YOUR BENEFITS ARE AND
REASON THE BILL CAME ABOUT LAST
YEAR. I'LL IS THAT A LOT OF
ORGANIZATIONS INCLUDING THE
STATE HERE AT THE CAPITOL WE
DON'T. HAVE A CHIU EMPLOYEE
ORIENTATION AND HAVING WORKED
FOR DIFFERENT JURISDICTIONS.
THE CITY AND THE COUNTY THEY DO
SOME VERY THOROUGH ORIENTATION
THAT GOES ON RIGHT NOW ALSO.
ATHLETES FOLKS WOULD YOU BELIEVE
IT'S BEING DONE.
IN A BLACK HOLE RIGHT NOW IT'S
NOT BEING DONE A BIT DO EXCEPT
THIRD PARTY VENDORS IT DOES
HAPPEN WILL RULING TO WORK WITH
THEM. AND CLEANUP LANGUAGE
SO FOR ME IT'S JUST COMMON SENSE
THAT NEVER BEING SUBMITTED
BENEFITS THE EMPLOYEE. NO WORK
SO WE WILL WORK WITH THEM.
THANK YOU.
I THINK ANY OTHER QUESTION
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
SENATE HEARING AND WOULD LIKE TO
CLOSE.
IF WE ARE THREE RIVAL. MOVED.
WE HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND A
MOTION BY SUMMER O'DONNELL
SECOND BY.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CERVANTES.
I DO HAVE IRAQ ON THIS BILLS
WELL THANK HER BRINGS BEFORE A
SECRETARY LIKE KALRA.
OKAY PROMOTION IS DO PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS RODRIGUEZ.
RODRIGUEZ AYE ALLEN.
BRO CERVANTES.
CERVANTES AYE COOLEY.
COOPER I COOPER O'DONNELL.
THE MOTION IS OUT FOR WILL KEEP
IT OPEN FOR THE LOCAL FOR OTHER
MEMBERS.
THAT WE HAVE ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
GONZALEZ FLETCHER HERE TO
PRESENT ON HER BUILD AB TWENTY
FORTY NINE.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER WHEN YOU'RE READY
QUITE.
THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS AB TWENTY FORTY
NINE IS A SIMPLE BILL THAT MAKES
PROCESS ANY PROCESSING COMMUNITY
COLLEGE CLASSIFIED SCHOOL
EMPLOYEE UNIONS MEMBERSHIP DUES.
UNIFORM AT THE CURRENT PROCEDURE
THAT EXISTS FOR PROCESSING
TEACHERS USE.
BY LINING THE STATUE FOR CLASS
RIGHT SCHOOL IN COMMUTE COLLEGE
EMPLOYEES THE BILL CLARIFIES AT
ME COLLEGE IN SCHOOL EMPLOYEE
PLAYERS ARE REQUIRED TO TRANSMIT
MEMBERSHIP DUES TO THE EMPLOYEES
LABOR REPRESENTATIVES.
IN THE CASE THAT AN EMPLOYEE
WOULD LIKE TO REVOKE THEIR
MEMBERSHIP THIS BILL WOULD ALSO
ESTABLISH A FIVE DAY
NOTIFICATION TO THE LABOR
REPRESENTATIVE TO ENSURE THAT
CAN GO THROUGH THE PROPER
VERIFICATION PROCESS.
FINALLY AB TWENTY FORTY NINE
INSURES THAT THE SCHOOL
DISTRICTS AND COMMITTEE COLLEGES
ARE INDEMNIFIED FOR MAKING JUICE
DEDUCTIONS BASED ON THE
EMPLOYEES MEMBERSHIP APPLICATION
AGREEMENT. THANK YOU AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FROM ABOUT.
NEAR IN SPORT.
UNDER MINUTEMEN MISTER CHAIRMAN
I JOBS A PROCESS WITH THE
COMPANY SCHOOL EMPLOYEES
ASSOCIATION.
I DON'T HAVE MUCH TO ADD TO
WHAT THE AUTHOR HAS ALREADY
STATED DE CHANGE TO NOT MAKE
SIGNIFICANT CHANGES. ARE NOT
CONSISTENT WITH CURRENT LAW AND
PRACTICE WITH RESPECT TO THE
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING PROCESS IN
CALIFORNIA. A JIBE.
WE HAVE A MOTION.
MOTION BY COMMERCIAL BONTA
SECOND BY SOME OF OUR O'DONNELL.
ANYONE ELSE'S SPORT IS MEASURE.
MICHELLE CAST OF THE SERVICE
EMPLOYEES INTERNATIONAL UNION
ALSO SUPPORT THINKING.
MICHAEL YOUNG WITH THE
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION ALSO
YOUR SUPPORT.
JOSH WILL GO GO WITH THE
AMERICAN FEDERATION OF STATE
COUNTY AND MUNICIPAL EMPLOYEES
IN SUPPORT.
SHANE GUSMAN ON BEHALF OF THE
TEAMSTERS IN SUPPORT.
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT.
PLATE FOR SECOND PERIOD CHRISTY
BAMA BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
PROFESSIONAL FIREFIGHTERS IN
SUPPORT.
WITH THAT TO ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS MEASURE.
SEEING NONE I ANY COMMIT
COMMENTS
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
SENATOR NUNN.
MY REALLY CLOSE IN YOUR BILL.
S. R. NEITHER.
THEY WERE MUCH I DO HAVE I
RECKON.
WE DO HAVE A MOTION AND SECOND
SECRETARY LIKE CALDERON.
THE MOTION IS DO PASSED TO
COMMITTEE ON HIGHER EDUCATION.
RODRIGUEZ I.
I VEGAS AYE ALLEN.
BRO CERVANTES.
CERVANTES AYE COOLEY.
COOPER.
O'DONNELL. O'DONNELL AYE.
THAT MEASURE BE HELD OPEN WE
HAVE TO RIO SO DEVELOP THANK
YOU.
WITH THAT I WILL BE PRESENTING
OUR MIND IF I CAN HAVE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER O'DONNELL. CHAIR WHILE I
PRESENT
.
YOU MAY PERCEIVE ALREADY.
CHAIR MEMBERS I'M HERE TO
PRESENT. AB TWENTY SIX NINETY
SIX THIS BILL WAS SIMPLY OUT.
THE SEPARATE TRUST OF THE CCPOA
C. A. H. P. AND PARKED EXISTING
LAW THAT WOULD ALLOW THEM TO
OFFER. REGIONAL RATES TO THE
MEMBERSHIP AND THEY CHOOSE TOE
TO DO SO IN THE FUTURE.
A SIMILAR BILL S. B. FIVE NINETY
NINE.
PORTANTINO WAS VOTED WAS VETOED
BY THE GOVERNOR LAST YEAR BUT
WAS BUT WITH INTERESTED PARTIES
ARE NEGOTIATING TERMS OF
DIFFERENCE.
IT'S THAT ARE SPECTRUM TRIBAL.
THE ANY OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
SING NOT ANY OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL SING OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL.
AYE ANY COMMENT FROM
THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
SAYING NO COMMENT.
.
I'LL MOVE THE BILL.
THEY ARE.
IT'S BEEN MOVED AND SECONDED YOU
MAY CLOSE.
SHORTGRASS REMOTE.
UP PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS ONLY READ THE
MOTION OF HER PLEASE.
THE MOTION IS.
DO WE HAVE THE MOTION YOU
PASSED TO APPROPRIATE YOU PASTOR
APPROPRIATIONS EMOTION PLEASE
READ THE.
COLOR.
RODRIGUEZ AYE RODRIGUEZ AYE
ALLEN BROUGH CERVANTES.
CERVANTES AYE COOLEY.
COOPER.
O'DONNELL AYE O'DONNELL AYE.
THE BILL'S ON CALL
.
COOLEY IS AYE ON.
TWENTY SIX NINETY SIX.
JUST HAVE SOME BILLS ON ALL. BUT
I THINK HER DROWNED OUT HERE.
SO THAT WOULD DO OF OF THE ONES
THAT ARE STILL LONG CALL I WILL
GO WITH CONSENT CALENDAR FIRST.
WHO WAS MISSING ON CONSECUTIVE?
CERVANTES.
CERVANTES AYE CONSENT CALENDAR.
AND THAT MEASURE GOES OUT.
FIVE WELL.
AB TWENTY ONE.
TO.
TWENTY SEVENTEEN.
ITEM REMEMBERS WANTED LIKE
ATLANTA.
ADAM MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS.
AND THE BILL IS OUT FIVE ZERO.
COOLEY FOR AB TWENTY FORTY NINE.
AB TWENTY FORTY NINE.
YOU PASS
I AM HIGHER EDUCATION.
COOLEY AYE.
AND CERVANTES GIGOLO.
OKAY.
THAT MEASURE IS OUT.
NEXT ONE OF.
FILE ITEM NUMBER THREE AB TWENTY
ONE SIXTY THURMAN.
MOTIONS PASSED TO HIGHER
EDUCATION.
OF CERVANTES.
CERVANTES I. AND COOLEY.
COOLEY AYE.
AND THAT MOTION IS UP FIVE ZERO.
THE NEXT ONE PHONE NUMBER FOR AB
TWENTY FOUR FIFTEEN.
PATH TWO APPROPRIATIONS COOLEY.
OKAY COOLEY AYE COOLEY AYE.
AND THAT MEASURES OUT FOUR ZERO.
AND WE DID DOES.
CONSENT CALENDAR IS OUT AS WELL.
THERE'S ONLY ONE AB TWENTY FOUR
EIGHTY ONE.
YOU GET ON CONSENT.
PHONE OF ONE ON BECAUSE.
FAR NUMBER SIX AB TWENTY SIX
NINETY SIX RODRIGUEZ.
CORRECT.
THE MOTION IS DO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS COOPER ARE.
COOPER I.
AND WHO REALLY.
COOLEY AYE.
AND WHAT YOURSELF IN THAT MOTION
IS UP SIX ZERO.
THAT'S OUR TO DO HAVE ALL OF
THEM.
SUMMER GRAPHICALLY A ONE MORE
WHICH WAS THAT WHEN I AB TWENTY
NINE SEVENTY.
DO PASS TWO APPROPRIATIONS
COOPER AB TWENTY NINE SEVEN.
HIS AND I.
SCHOOL. REMEMBER COOPER I THINK
YOU HAVE.
I WANT.
OF PHONE NUMBER TO AB TWENTY
FORTY NINE GONZALEZ FLETCHER.
DO PATH TO HIGHER EDUCATION.
COOPER.
COOPER I THAT MOTION IS OUT.
FIVE ZERO.
I THINK A FEW OF YOUR.
SO WITHOUT A WE HAVE ALL THE
BILLS.
DON AND WITHOUT THIS MEDIC
MEETING IS ADJOURNED THANK YOU